[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana
en américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un repaso por las noticias
más destacadas acerca de la pandemia en
nuestro continente yo soy mar aclara
calle y estoy aquí en reemplazo de
santiago lópez quien está en una
asignación de trabajo veamos entonces
algunos de los temas de los que
hablaremos en esta emisión
hoy vamos a referirnos al regreso a las
clases presenciales los alumnos de
paraguay ya volvieron a las escuelas
mientras que en argentina solo lo han
hecho la capital y dos provincias y cada
vez más países levantan las medidas en
uruguay por ejemplo ya no será necesario
el pase sanitario para entrar a eventos
públicos en nuestra consulta con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez nuestro
asesor médico y científico miraremos
cuál es la conexión entre el aumento de
los trastornos alimenticios en los
adolescentes y el aislamiento que hubo
en los momentos más difíciles de la
pandemia también explicaremos cómo
funcionan los nuevos test que detectan
el kobe 19 en la saliva a través de la
luz además en esta emisión veremos la
historia de los transportistas de eeuu
que se inspiraron en las protestas de
canadá y ahora se dirigen hacia
washington para exigir el levantamiento
de las mascarillas y también para
mostrar su rechazo a la aplicación de la
vacuna contra el coronavirus
comencemos entonces en la parte norte de
nuestro continente para mirar cómo ha
avanzado la pandemia de kobe 19 de sus
inicios las siguientes cifras son del
conteo que lleva a la universidad johns
hopkins en canadá se han detectado más
de 32 millones de contagios y se han
reportado cerca de 36 mil muertes a
causa del virus
eeuu es el país del mundo con más casos
al confirmar más de 78 millones desde el
inicio del brote allí los decesos ya son
casi un millón y en méxico ha habido 5,4
millones de positivos y alrededor de 317
mil fallecimientos
ahora saludo a esta hora al doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
y asesor científico de france 24 ya está
con nosotros para nuestra habitual
consulta doctor pérez como siempre es un
gusto tenerlo aquí en france 24 y
empezamos hablando entonces de los
adolescentes porque según un estudio
publicado por los cdc de eeuu esta
población tiene una tendencia al aumento
de los trastornos alimenticios y a la
ansiedad en relación con el aislamiento
que se vivió a causa de la pandemia cómo
fueron esos impactos y cómo están
relacionados tanto los trastornos como
el encierro
aclara lo que nos muestra el csd es algo
que conocemos que es la enfermedad
mental importante que ha sido es
exacerbación de la enfermedad mental
esta vez en esta población joven y
adolescente donde se incrementa la
ansiedad y la depresión también con
trastornos alimenticios que van
relacionados con estas patologías y
sobre todo por esta situación de
confinamiento
incertidumbre de miedo a la muerte y de
poca esperanza desesperanza la
enfermedad mental es una pandemia tan
grave y la post pandemia y la enfermedad
en tal base números grandes desafíos que
tengamos se registra incremento en
cuatro veces más de patología mental
antes de la pandemia en esta población
ha del adolescente queremos redoblar
esfuerzos para poder
acompañarlos y poder entender que la
enfermedad mental no es una enfermedad
que se deba analizar sino que todos
debemos enfrentar adecuadamente
doctor y hablemos de otro estudio que se
publicó hoy que se publicó en la revista
the lancet porque ellos están diciendo
que es una condición muy rara que los
jóvenes entre los 12 y los 20 años que
se vacuna el 19 desarrolle lo que se
llama síndrome inflamatorio
multisistema en qué consiste este
síndrome y por qué es poca la
probabilidad de que yo se dé en estos
jóvenes
este síndrome inflamatorio
multisistémico eso lo conocimos desde
los principios de la pandemia en italia
sobre todo en población pediátrica y en
el transcurso de estos dos años hemos
visto que si bien es infrecuente no
dejan aparecer casos sobre todo en
población joven y se relaciona es a una
situación que pasa unas dos a tres
semanas después del coito en donde hay
una respuesta en sistema inmunológico
inadecuada y afecta a los órganos desde
la piel cerebro del corazón y es
necesario utilizar modificadores de la
respuesta para evitar esta situación ya
que la importancia a vacunar en niños y
adolescentes y james vemos que los niños
adolescentes no fallecen si pueden tener
esta complique esta complicación de la
respuesta inflamatoria sistémica este
síndrome y por eso es necesario también
reenfocar la vacunación para prevenir
esta complicación del co2 y pasamos de
hablar de la vacunación a hablar de las
pruebas para detectar el kobe 19 porque
en españa concretamente el instituto de
cien de ciencias fotónicas de barcelona
está desarrollando un dispositivo
que podría detectar el kobe 19 en la
saliva a través de la luz doctor
explíquenos un poco cómo puede funcionar
este dispositivo y por qué la luz es tan
importante
realmente es un proceso muy ingenioso en
donde lo que se hace es recolectar unas
gotas de saliva y utilizar anticuerpos
es decir defensas que reconocen el virus
pero estas defensas están marcados con
fluoruro zeína que se puede colocar en
un dispositivo que puede leerlo como una
luz fluorescente y detectar pequeñas
cantidades esta es una fase experimental
con
150 pacientes en donde encontraron
sensibilidades y especies cercana al 90%
muy similar a una pcr muy similar a una
plantilla nos son otra una forma de
hacer diagnóstico que puede ser más
portable incluso más económica y debemos
esperar a la evaluación clínica y
recordar que una prueba diagnóstica no
solamente hace la confirmación del
código si 9 sino se debe tener en cuenta
el momento en tiempo lógico y los
síntomas gritos del paciente pero son
buenas noticias porque puede ser
accesible más económica y disponible en
varias partes del mundo bueno ya
miraremos si esta evaluación clínica la
supera este dispositivo para lograr lo
que usted nos está contando y ahora
vámonos américa concretamente américa
latina porque cada vez más países están
levantando las restricciones como que ya
no es obligatorio el uso de tapabocas o
permiten el aforo al cien por ciento es
hora de levantar estas medidas
yo creo que hay que empezar a dar pasos
hacia asia
por ejemplo retirar los tratados de
espacios libres no es retirarlos del
todo y hay que hacer algunos cambios
paulatinos para retormar sobre todo la
confianza en la sociedad y ya conocemos
que los espacios abiertos y bien
ventilados no son el mecanismo que se
adquieren las transmisiones en los
espacios cerrados y mal ventilados sin
embargo esto de acompañarse de un
proceso de vacunación que todavía
estamos retardados nosotros debemos
saber que la vacunación se llama
completa cuando tienen tres dosis o dos
dosis cuando se utiliza el biológico de
janssen pero en una vacunación
incompleta no asegura retirar los
tapabocas debemos seguir creciendo en
vacunación ir avanzando en desmontar los
tapabocas pero sobre todo con pedagogía
social con acercamiento y brindando de
la información a las personas porque
para las personas quitarse un tapabocas
ahora que hemos insistido durante los
años que es necesario pues también tiene
un poco de miedo y limitaciones entonces
debemos acompañarnos con educación para
poder hacerlo paulatinamente
bueno y aquí le haremos el seguimiento a
esto gracias doctor por estar con
nosotros y en otras noticias desde su
inicio la pandemia de kobe 19 ago hizo
la inseguridad alimentaria en diferentes
países latinoamericanos y del caribe
esto provocó un retroceso en los logros
alcanzados en la lucha contra el hambre
en la región en las últimas dos décadas
en otra parte de las autoridades
insisten en la vacunación como la mejor
manera de vencer el coronavirus tal como
lo decía nuestro doctor veamos más en el
siguiente informe los efectos de la
pandemia de kobe 19 en américa latina y
el caribe fueron tan devastadores como
los de una bomba atómica
así lo afirmó julio berdegué el
representante regional de la
organización de las naciones unidas para
la alimentación y la agricultura
esto porque borraron todo lo logrado en
las dos últimas décadas en la lucha
contra el hambre y en el acceso de las
mujeres al empleo vuelvo a insistir en
américa latina' comida hay
comida y lo que falta es dinero para
comprar la comida entonces en la medida
en que se recupere la economía y el
empleo pues eso va a ayudar muchísimo a
disminuir las tasas de hambre según la
organización panamericana de la salud
del hambre en la región está en su punto
más alto desde el año 2000 en tan solo
un año texto de la pandemia de comí 19
el número de personas que viven con
hambre aumentó en 13,8 millones
alcanzando un total de 59 7 millones de
personas la ope s también indicó que 4
de cada 10 personas en la región es
decir
267 millones de personas experimentaron
inseguridad alimentaria moderado grave
en 2020 60 millones más que en 2019 sin
embargo no afectó por igual a hombres y
mujeres en 2020 el 40 y 18 de las
mujeres de la región se quedaron sin
alimentos o pasaron un día o más sin
comer en comparación con el 32 2% de los
hombres las autoridades sanitarias han
dejado en claro que la vacunación es la
herramienta más eficiente de vencerla de
coronavirus y dada la desigualdad en la
distribución la organización mundial de
la salud informó que ha creado un centro
en corea del sur para formar a los
países de ingresos bajos y medios en la
producción de sus propias vacunas y
terapias
producing en marne bucks in sports and
byers chulo willingham countries
producir vacunas de aire nm plantea
algunas barreras para los países de
ingresos bajos y medios como sus costes
el hecho de que requieran una cadena de
frío que es difícil y cara de
implementar también requiere una mano de
obra cualificada y formada en la
actualidad los centros de formación
envío fabricación se encuentran
principalmente en países de renta alta y
funcionan con un sistema de pago lo que
los pone fuera del alcance de muchos
países de renta baja bay system putting
out of reach for men in love in camp
countries a pesar de que américa latina
y el caribe ya inoculó con el esquema
completo a más del 63 por ciento de su
población total 20 de los 35 países de
las américas aún no vacunan ni al 40% de
su población total según la américas
society una organización estadounidense
la educación en barbate y el diálogo
sobre las américas
y ahora vamos al sur del continente en
argentina haya algunos estudiantes
volvieron a la presencialidad y se
espera que todos comiencen a hacerlo a
partir del 2 de marzo los niños y niñas
no necesitarán pase sanitario para
entrar a las escuelas y las clases ya no
serán con turnos burbuja por lo que los
menores podrán encontrarse con otros
grupos vamos entonces a buenos aires
donde estaba nuestro corresponsal
natalio cosoi natalio gracias por estar
con nosotros y cuéntenos si no habrá
turnos burbuja y la presencialidad ya es
para todos entonces qué restricciones
existen y cómo protegerse del cob y 19
bueno este ha sido un inicio de clases
muy muy esperado después de dos años muy
duros de pandemia esperado como un
regreso finalmente algo parecido a la
normalidad las clases ya comenzaron aquí
en la ciudad de buenos aires y en otras
dos provincias y el inicio en el resto
del país será el día 2 de marzo hay una
serie de protocolos mucho menos
estrictos que los del año 2021
protocolos guías que se están
implementando en las escuelas se deberán
implementar cuando comiences en las
provincias que están por comenzar
incluyen por supuesto una promoción
persistente de la vacunación en menores
el uso de barbijo de cubrebocas en la
escuela primaria esto es diferente en el
caso de la ciudad de buenos aires donde
sólo será obligatorio a partir del
cuarto grado los primeros grados de
primaria no deberán usar barbijo en el
aula también una asistencia cuidada que
tiene que ver con no concurrir al aula
en el caso de que alguno de los de los
chicos de los estudiantes esté con
síntomas o haya dado positivo para ccoo
vivo en circunstancias también en el
caso de contactos estrechos por supuesto
la promoción de la ventilación en las
aulas la higiene y la limpieza y
mantener en lo posible la distancia
social el propósito de este regreso a
clases natalio cómo está la vacunación
en esta población de jóvenes a propósito
que entre los 12 y los 17 años los
argentinos pueden aspirar a una dosis de
refuerzo como va
bueno eso es clave con este regreso con
este regreso a las aulas en el país las
vacunaciones menores del gobierno
nacional ha hecho una campaña bastante
importante para promover la vacunación
en menores ha sido un poco más lenta al
principio sobre todo con los más
pequeños con algunas dudas de los padres
pero esas dudas en general se fueron
despejando en la mayoría de los casos en
algunos casos también fue difícil lograr
que los adolescentes terminarán por
ejemplo de ir completando sus esquemas
pero en todo caso es algo que va
avanzando en este momento entre 3 y 17
años que es la edad justamente escolar y
a partir de la cual hay vacunación para
menores en argentina hay cerca del
65% de la población de esas edades con
esquema completo o más dosis hay un 20%
que solo tiene una dosis y hay algo más
de 15 por ciento de esa población sin
vacunar
y ahora hablemos del panorama de la
pandemia cómo van los contagios que han
caído drásticamente desde enero cómo se
siente la situación epidemiológica en
argentina
si bien los expertos aseguran que
todavía no se pueden descartar nuevas
olas que pueden llegar nuevas variantes
aquí hay una sensación
de tranquilidad de alivio de que tal vez
lo peor ya pasó de hecho bueno luego de
esta última ola que se ha estado
viviendo en argentina cuando los casos
diarios han llegado a superar los
100.000 ahora han venido cayendo en
forma consistente con varios días con
casos por debajo de los 20.000 y por
supuesto dos es datos clave que también
vienen cayendo los fallecimientos y la
presión sobre las terapias intensivas en
el país la ocupación de camas en terapia
intensiva así que como te decía una
sensación por lo pronto de alivio frente
a lo que es la pandemia de kobe 19 en
argentina gracias natalio por este
reporte desde buenos aires y brevemente
les presentamos otras noticias
destacadas de la semana en nuestro
continente previamente les cuento que
costa rica relajara las medidas a partir
del 7 de marzo los carros podrán
circular después de media noche los
establecimientos volverán a abrir en
horario regular y también aumentará el
aforo en los lugares públicos y es que
en el país los contagios bajaron un 27
por ciento en la última semana mientras
que los fallecimientos disminuyeron un
3,2 por ciento también les comento que
en una sola semana la agencia nacional
de vigilancia sanitaria de brasil aprobó
la comercialización de dos marcas de
auto test así las personas podrán
hacerse el hisopado nasal ellos mismos y
saber en tan solo 15 minutos el
resultado de si tienen o no coronavirus
estas pruebas se podrán conseguir en las
farmacias brasileñas y brevemente
también les digo que el gobierno de
ecuador firmó un manifiesto de intención
con la farmacéutica sinovac para
instalar en los próximos dos años una
planta de vacunas contra el cob y 19 la
negociación comenzó el año pasado con la
visita del presidente ecuatoriano
guillermo lasso a china
y ahora hablemos de qué está pasando en
eeuu un pequeño grupo de transportistas
se está movilizando para llegar hasta
washington y protestar en contra de los
mandatos sanitarios por el kobe 19 el
llamado convoy del pueblo que partió
desde california está inspirado en el
movimiento canadiense del convoy de la
libertad sin embargo estas
manifestaciones llegan cuando los casos
y las hospitalizaciones por el virus
siguen disminuyendo en eeuu y además
cuando los mandatos se están relajando o
levantando
unas dos docenas de camiones de 18
ruedas y 50 camionetas y vehículos
pertenecientes al convoy del pueblo
iniciaron el pasado miércoles un viaje
de 11 días desde california hasta
washington para protestar en contra de
las restricciones impuestas por la
pandemia de kobe 19 siguiendo la línea
de las manifestaciones que paralizaron
ottawa la capital de canadá durante
semanas pero en una menor escala
actualmente estamos protestando contra
los estados de emergencia que se han
puesto en marcha y esperamos acabar con
todos los mandatos tanto de mascarilla
como de vacuna para todos los empleados
federales los trabajadores de la salud y
el personal militar del departamento de
defensa en washington se están haciendo
preparativos para la eventual llegada de
convoys y otras protestas similares en
los próximos días el pentã gono aprobó
el envío de 700 tropas de la guardia
nacional del distrito de columbia que no
portarán armas y cuyo objetivo es ayudar
en los puestos de tráfico desde el
sábado hasta el 7 de marzo también se
aprobó el despliegue de unos 50
vehículos tácticos en los puestos de
tráfico aun así los manifestantes no dan
su brazo a torcer
y el gobierno tiene que empezar a
reconocer que el pueblo manda el
gobierno no está a cargo de nosotros
tenemos que poner fin a los manda
vinicius de méndez los camioneros están
haciendo sus demandas incluso cuando la
mayoría de los estados de la unión
americana ya han aliviado muchas de las
restricciones contra el kobe 19 el
estado de california eliminó la semana
pasada al requisito de mascarilla
universal sin embargo exige su uso
incluso a las personas vacunadas
únicamente en zonas de alto riesgo como
el transporte público las escuelas y los
centros sanitarios
en noticias de uruguay la republica
oriental comenzó a aplicar la cuarta
dosis de la vacuna contra el cobre 19
para mayores de 50 años con esto se
convierte en el segundo país del
continente en aplicarla después de chile
además en uruguay casi el 80% de la
población tiene el esquema ya completado
vamos entonces hasta a punta del este
con nuestra corresponsal karina dalmás
karina bienvenida a nuestro programa
cuéntenos entonces quiénes recibirán
esta dosis de refuerzo
las autoridades sanitarias de uruguay y
habilitaron las dosis de refuerzo de
vacunas contra el cob y 19 para los
adolescentes de 12 a 17 años con
comorbilidades también a los mayores de
50 años con afecciones en su salud entre
tanto a los mayores de 70 años podrán
recibir su cuarta dosis de refuerzo
contra el coronavirus tengan o no
afecciones de salud las autoridades
indicaron que de ahora en más no van a
estar calificando estas dosis como dosis
a la primera segunda tercera o cuarta
sino que se nombrarán como dosis de
refuerzo las personas deberán esperar en
320 180 días para recibir estas dosis
dependiendo de cuándo fue la última vez
que recibieron la dosis de la vacuna
contra el coquí 19 entretanto los
menores entre 5 y 11 años en los últimos
días también empezaron a recibir su
segunda dosis de vacunación contra el
cob y 19
y la vacunación no es lo único que está
avanzando uruguaya comenzó a levantar
ciertas medidas por ejemplo el pase
sanitario ya no se va a necesitar para
entrar a espacios públicos cuéntanos
entonces qué otras restricciones
cambiaron y cómo va a funcionar lo del
pase sanitario
el ministro de salud pública ni a las
salinas indicó que se eliminó el pases
sanitarios para los eventos sociales
públicos al aire libre entretanto se
permitirá también el 100% de las fueron
los eventos en recintos cerrados cuando
las personas que concurran tengan tres
dosis de vacuna también se modificó el
periodo de aislamiento para las personas
que hayan tenido tres dosis de vacuna
contra el cob y 19 el aislamiento será
de 5 días y no de 7 como era
anteriormente
en los últimos días también se generó
una polémica en torno a una
recomendación del ministerio de salud
pública que indicaba de cara a la vuelta
a clases
como tomar medidas en caso de un brote
dentro de un centro educativo el
ministro salinas recomendó que tanto
vacunados como no vacunados pero que
hayan tenido la enfermedad recientemente
no deberían aislarse pero si aquellos
niños no vacunados esto genera una
polémica de las autoridades de la
educación dijeron que la recomendación
la encontraban discriminatoria y por
tanto el presidente luis lacalle pou
dijo que ésta no se va a estar aplicando
en el nuevo protocolo que estarán
utilizando las autoridades de la
educación en la vuelta a clases
y para terminar hablemos de un hallazgo
de la academia porque en montevideo
publicaron un estudio que habla sobre
cómo se han impactado negativamente en
los jóvenes sus destrezas cognitivas y
motrices en el aislamiento cuéntenos más
de este estudio
el informe de la sociedad para la
investigación del desarrollo infantil de
la universidad de la república del
uruguay hecho en los menores y su
impacto tras la pandemia de kobe 19
indicó que los retrasos en las destrezas
de los niños han sido diferentes y
desparejas a lo largo de sus habilidades
destacó que el mayor retraso se ocurrió
en cuanto al lenguaje
las matemáticas y las habilidades
motrices indicaron que además de este
retraso cognitivo los niños de 5 años
sufrieron también un impacto en la
conducta en su actitud hacia el
aprendizaje
esta información es muy relevante dado
que lo ocurrido en la edad preescolar
hacia la escolar o sea entre los 5 45 a
los 6 años se impacta el futuro de sus
habilidades cognitivas de estos niños
más adulta esta información será tomada
en cuenta por las autoridades educativas
quienes también indicaron que en el
regreso a clase se estará realizando una
evaluación del estado
de habilidades de los niños y estarían
aplicando la currícula educacional de
forma de adaptarse a poder favorecer el
desarrollo de las habilidades de los
niños de acuerdo a su edad pero no
necesariamente
utilizando la currícula educativa previa
a la pandemia
estaremos atentos a esa evaluación
gracias karina por estar con nosotros
veamos cómo ha avanzado la vacunación en
el continente americano hoy vamos a
hacer un recorrido por países
suramericanos y su porcentaje de
población vacunada según los datos de
our world in data el 65 por ciento de
los colombianos ya tiene el esquema
completo mientras que el 15% está
parcialmente vacunado en perú el 70% de
la población tiene todas las dosis que
el 6% todavía no completa su vacunación
mientras que en bolivia las cifras son
más bajas pues el 47% ya tiene la
totalidad de las vacunas y el 11% tiene
el esquema parcial
las autoridades de ecuador están
pensando en relajar las medidas
sanitarias dentro de los próximos meses
ya que más del 84 por ciento de su
población tiene todo el esquema completo
de vacunación contra el coronavirus esto
según cifras oficiales un caso similar
es el de colombia que aunque tienen un
menor porcentaje de población vacunada
este país ya levantó el uso del
tapabocas en espacios públicos y en
ciertos municipios
arianna villacorta nostra de todos los
detalles
una inversión de más de 600 millones de
dólares en vacunas contra el covent 19
además de las que han recibido a través
de donaciones ha permitido a ecuador
inocular con una dosis a más del 88 por
ciento de su población total a más del
84 por ciento con dos dosis y a más del
21 por ciento con dosis de refuerzo
cifras que junto al 68 por ciento de
positividad en pruebas pcr y casos
reportados hacen posible que el país
andino investigue si el 92 por ciento de
su población es inmune al cob y 19 un
análisis que será dado a conocer dentro
de unos tres meses aún así y suscribió
un manifiesto de intención con la
farmacéutica china sinovac para el
establecimiento de una planta de vacunas
contra el coi 19 y otras enfermedades
mientras que la farmacéutica médicamente
ecuatoriana anunció la firma de un
acuerdo de colaboración con el
estadounidense moderna para la
distribución y comercialización de su
vacuna en territorio ecuatoriano en
efecto el gobierno de guillermo lasso
considera relajar las medidas sanitarias
obviamente no aparece alguna otra
variante como la o micro y es que
seguimos con una tasa de vacunación así
de buena como ahora posiblemente para
fines de marzo abril ya podremos dejar
de utilizarla la mascarilla en lugares
abiertos algo que el gobierno colombiano
ya procedió a hacer luego de extensas
conversaciones durante dos semanas con
el comité asesor epidemiológico
aquellos municipios
cuya vacunación cuya vacunación
supere el 70 por ciento podrán ya
levantar el uso del tapabocas en
espacios públicos
medida política que aplica únicamente
para lugares al aire libre excluyendo de
esta manera al sistema de transporte
público restaurantes y otros espacios
cerrados esta decisión ocurre tras
registrarse menos de tres mil contagios
diarios por coronavirus por primera vez
en 2022 el ministro de salud de este
país fernando ruiz explicó que esto
servirá dice vivo para que quienes no se
hayan inmunizado lo hagan según un
estudio realizado por la organización
our world in that a más del 65% de la
población total de esta nación que
cuenta con más de 50 millones de
habitantes se ha inoculado con el
esquema completo más de 6 millones de
personas han contraído el virus y más de
138.000 personas han muerto a causa de
esto
y otro de los países americanos que
comenzó a levantar las medidas contra el
cob y 19 es paraguay el gobierno de
mario abdo benítez quitó casi todas las
restricciones excepto la del uso del
tapabocas en ciertos lugares vamos
entonces a asunción dónde está nuestro
corresponsal fernando box ya fernando un
placer estar con ustedes y explíquenos
cuáles son las medidas que levantan y
por qué el gobierno tomó esta decisión
luego de más de dos años lo cual el
presidente mariotto es literal dispuesto
por decreto protocolos y medidas
sanitarias que buscaron frenar el
contagio del joven 19 paraguay esta
semana el gobierno ha anunciado que
eliminó todas estas restricciones
excepto la de luz suelta pago
obligatorio en lugares cerrados y en
lugares abiertos donde no hay la
suficiente distancia entre las personas
también se ha eliminado la restricción
de circulación en el área pública en
determinados horarios que estuvo
presente durante toda la pandemia de
esta manera el gobierno pretende
oxigenar a los sectores más golpeados
por la pandemia
específicamente de la astronomía o el de
los eventos que ahora ya podrán empezar
a operar al 100 por ciento de sus
capacidades y sin exigir el certificado
de vacunación a sus clientes y también
ya también está acompañada por otras
acciones económicas del gobierno como la
prolongación del programa de subsidio o
medidas tributarias enfocadas a
determinados rubros con 4 la cuál se
pretende reactivar la economía paraguaya
y otra de las noticias es que en
paraguay ya volvieron los estudiantes a
la presencialidad eso pasó esta semana
sin embargo la decisión generó polémica
porque
esta semana más de un millón y medio de
estudiantes de primaria y secundaria de
paraguay porque van a las aulas con
clases 100% presenciales luego de casi
dos años de una educación virtual y a
distancia el retorno a las aulas no
estuvo exento de críticas hacer mi
interior educación paraguayo y debido a
que nuevamente quedó evidenciada la
falta de infraestructuras las escuelas y
colegios públicos hoy son más de 8000
las instituciones educativas que
necesitan reacondicionamiento incluso
varias de ellas con riesgo de derrumbe
el gobierno argumentó que estas obras no
se hicieron durante los últimos dos años
a pesar de las aulas estaban vacías
debido a que se priorizó el
fortalecimiento del sistema de salud
pública en pandemia por otro lado esta
semana también en mi interior es al
último el interior educación han
comenzado a suministrar vacunas contra
el cob y 19 en escuelas y colegios con
el objetivo de aumentar los números de
vacunación en la población de niños de 5
a 11 años y adolescentes
y a pesar del debate que usted nos
cuenta una noticia positiva es que el
regreso a clases se da en medio de una
disminución drástica de contagios como
esta la pandemia en paraguay
luego un comienzo de año en el que se
registró una nueva ola de contagio de
coronavirus e incluso récords
estadísticos de casos diarios
confirmados para ver nuevamente ahora
estará reduciendo los números de
contagiados internados y muertes por
coronarios
a pesar de que luego las cifras de
pacientes hospitalizados continúan
preocupando las autoridades sanitarias
tendría seis y siete semanas que se
observa una caída en la curva de
contagio de kobe 19 de continuar esta
tendencia en la proyección del interior
salud es que el nivel de contagio
ingrese a una necesitaba baja en marzo
próximo y llegue así las marginales en
abril
está en situación de hacer yo en
septiembre y noviembre del año pasado en
la que paraba en registró su menor
cantidad de casos y muertes diarias de
kobe desde la primera ola de contagios
si bien el gobierno esta semana
levantó todas las medidas sanitarias y
restricciones que pretendían frenar el
contagio de coronavirus todo el país
vidrios ya lo que continúa exhortando a
la población a seguir unas medidas de
cuidado y así seguirá ganando la curva
fernando box ya gracias por este reporte
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 destacadas en redes
nuestros colegas de prensa libre de
guatemala hablan del contexto en el que
los escolares volvieron a las clases
presenciales el pasado 21 de febrero y
es que 224 de los 340 municipios del
país están en alerta roja por el
coronavirus según el semáforo
epidemiológico de esta nación y otra de
las noticias es que la frontera entre
venezuela y brasil se reabre después de
dos años de haberse cerrado a causa de
la pandemia el diario punto es de españa
afirmaba que la decisión la ejecutó el
estado venezolano de bolívar luego de la
orden presidencial de nicolás maduro con
esto se normalizan los intercambios
económicos entre ambos
y también les cuento que en chile el
gobierno de sebastián piñera está
impulsando la vacunación en los menores
entre los 3 y los 5 años de edad sólo el
40 por ciento de ellos tiene el esquema
completo según el ministerio de salud
esto se da pocos días de que se retomen
las clases presenciales y con el 100%
del aforo en este país que comenzarán a
partir del 2 de marzo
y este fue nuestro resumen semanal de
qué está pasando con el cob y 19 en
américa los despide maría clara calle y
les agradezco en nombre de todo el
equipo por estar con nosotros
[Música]